now you may never have bloating after
you watch this video now people do know
that there's certain foods that cause
bloating like beans legumes fruit sugars
especially like lactose from milk
too much fiber especially if you eat too
much bran in other types of fibers and
as a side note if someone has irritable
bowel syndrome you should never ever
ever give them bran that will just
completely tear them up but let's say
you eliminate a lot of the foods that
cause bloating and you still have
bloating okay then what now there's
something very fundamental that you need
to understand to be able to get rid of
bloating and that is this thing called
bile bile is made by your liver it's
stored in the gallbladder and it has
three main purposes and I'm going to
give you a really good demo to help you
understand bile bile is
dishwashing detergent that's what bile
is okay so we have some fat here and we
have detergent we have soap so if we mix
these together
okay and we shake it up
you can see
it emulsifies now what does emulsify
mean emulsify means to break down
something into smaller droplets so when
we add bile which is a detergent to Fat
you get these smaller particles thereby
increasing the surface size so your
pancreas can release the lipase enzyme
to break it down fully for it to be
absorbed in the small intestine so the
first purpose of bile is to help you
absorb certain things in fats especially
the important things like fat soluble
vitamins vitamin A D E K1 K2 and other
things like omega-3 fatty acids very
very important so that's number one
number two bile helps you eliminate
excess cholesterol in fact bile is the
primary thing that regulates the amount
of cholesterol because you have
cholesterol that comes from the diet and
you also have cholesterol that your body
makes bile is there to make sure that it
does not build up in the body and this
is why one cause of high cholesterol or
high lipids is really a bile deficiency
and number three and this relates to
your bloating bile is anti-microbial in
other words it kills microbes that are
in the small intestine normally you
should not have a lot of microbes in the
small intestine especially the microbes
that make certain gases like hydrogen
and methane when you have too much
hydrogen or methane you're going to get
bloating and that is called small
intestinal bacterial
overgrowth and what's interesting about
that is when people had their
gallbladders removed the studies showed
that their risk for getting
small intestinal bacterial overgrowth
goes up now there's something else that
occurs when you don't have enough bile
you get undigested fat that tends to
accumulate in the small intestine and
now that forces the intestine to try to
digest it and so we have this decreased
transient time right because it's not
going through very easily and that alone
is another cause of bloating because
you're going to get excess fermentation
and on top of that bile helps to
lubricate the colon and this is why not
having enough bile could cause
constipation and having too much bile
can give you diarrhea so when people get
bloating they usually take some
medication they might take some enzymes
they might take a probiotic or maybe
even some type of a medication that
takes a spasm out but what they really
need is bile salts and so if you're
interested in a really good product that
not only has purified bile salts but
also has additional things like enzymes
things to acidify the stomach herbs to
help thin the bile so as you can see
bile is so essential for your digestion
and it's stored with the gallbladder
which is not an extra organ that they
might tell you that you really don't
need and so whether you have your
gallbladder removed or you just have a
deficiency in bile all sorts of things
can happen in addition to having
bloating as well and so I'm going to
give you some additional information on
that right here what are the symptoms of
low bile well you can develop
hypothyroidism why because you need bile
to help convert T4 to T3 the active form
of the thyroid hormone and if there's
anything going on with the liver whether
you have a fatty liver or it's filled
with scar tissue you may find that you
might not get this conversion from T4 to
T3 on the flip side let's say your
thyroid is in a hyper State you have
Graves it's hyperthyroidism and it's
moving too fast that would be one
contraindication that you don't want to
give the person bile salts because it's
going to speed up the thyroid a little
bit more if the real cause is a
deficiency of bile and that's why I'm
covering all these symptoms right here
because if you're trying to figure out
is my problem with bloating a lack of
bile you probably have other symptoms
that relate to that okay next one is
greasy stool you might leave skid marks
in your toilet why because there's still
fat there this fat that's never been
digested your stool actually could float
if you have too much fat in it that
would be an indication of low bile and a
couple others that's not on the list
number one the stool color is a pale or
even gray that could be a severe bile
deficiency another one is you're not
satisfied after you eat why because you
can't break down and absorb these fat
soluble nutrients that are supposed to
satisfy you so even though the food
might be nutrient dense it's really
about you not absorbing those nutrients
all right we already covered bloating we
covered sibo
and next one is right-sided discomfort
and I'm talking about underneath the
right rib cage right through here you
have your small intestine right here you
have your gallbladder right here and
that can refer up to the right uh trap
right here or back into the rhomboid on
the right side it can come up all
through here because there's a little
nerve from your gallbladder to the
diaphragm to all the way up through here
okay and then we have high cholesterol I
already talked about that
gallstones okay what is gallstones that
is a super concentrated cholesterol
situation where the cholesterol is
turning into crystals why it's because
you're lacking bile that is normally
supposed to break up and eliminate this
extra cholesterol all right next one fat
soluble vitamin deficiencies like a
vitamin A deficiency you're going to
notice that with your vision at night
driving it's hard to see in the dark you
might notice with your skin and low
vitamin D that could show up in a lot of
different ways low back pain
inflammation
um you get sick easily you can also have
a vitamin E deficiency that can show up
in a lot of things too it can show up in
weak muscles after you exercise it's
taking you way too long to recovery your
Skin's bad and you have vitamin K1 which
could be you bleed easily now if it's
vitamin K2 you might get calcium buildup
on your teeth is tartar or in the joints
and the last symptom would be omega-3
fatty acid deficiency so
you know people take cod liver oil fish
oil to get this omega-3 and it's not
just important for your heart health
it's good for your cognitive function
and mood and it's an anti-inflammatory
so even though you're taking it on a
regular basis the problem could be
you're just not absorbing it because you
don't have enough bile
all right let's talk about the causes of
a bile deficiency situation well having
your gallbladder out is the obvious one
because now we have no way of storing
that bile between meals
what we have is we have a tube from your
liver that's making the bile directly
into the small intestine and it's just
kind of trickling through we don't have
any ability to regulate it but I will
say this that there have been a lot of
reports that people tend to grow back uh
their gallbladder and even remnants of a
gallbladder Okay so
that's a possibility okay so you may be
able to grow it back if you had yours
removed and I'm not making a joke about
that all right low-fat diets when you go
on a diet that's low especially in
saturated fat there's nothing there to
stimulate the the bile production or the
gallbladder contraction so that's
another cause of a deficiency of bile
and this is why vegans have a higher
tendency to have gallstones because they
don't produce enough bile because you're
not eating saturated fats or animal
products
antibiotics now why would an antibiotic
cause a low bile situation well guess
what there's primary bile that's made by
your liver that's stored in the
gallbladder and you have secondary bile
that is produced from your
microbiome in your gut so if you don't
have that you can't produce the
secondary bile that you also need to
help out with the situation and this
explains why diarrhea can also cause a
loss of this microflora and then you can
end up with a loss of bile from that as
well and that triggers another thought
let's say for example you did a lot of
colon cleansing right colon hydrotherapy
where you're getting rid of a lot of
waste from your body well you better put
those microbes back and you may need to
add some bile salts because if you're
removing a lot of the microbes from your
gut you're not only going to be
deficient in the microbes you're going
to be deficient in the biome that they
produce a couple other points high
estrogen whether the person's on birth
control pills from a replacement therapy
or they just had a baby and this is why
pregnancy can increase the risk of
gallstones because of this estrogen
situation and how it affects the liver
high amounts of insulin okay that comes
from eating a lot of carbs and frequent
eating can diminish your bile Reserves
High cortisol especially if it's from
medication like prednisone that can
really mess up your gallbladder your
liver as well as the production of bile
and then too much omega-6 fats those are
the unsaturated fats that are very
inflammatory can really throw off your
bile reserve and then having a fatted
liver it could be even an inflamed liver
or even a liver that's erotic okay
cirrhosis why because your bile is made
from your liver and if there's damage in
the liver you can't produce the bile
all right what's the game plan the to-do
list
well make sure you have enough fat in
your diet I'm talking about healthy fats
not the omega-6 have omega-3 have enough
saturated fats to trigger this process
don't go low-fat in anything you don't
have to spike the fats tremendously but
just just don't go low fat probiotics or
foods that help build up your gut Flora
like fermented sauerkraut for example
number three intermittent fasting can
greatly help because first of all you're
lowering insulin secondly you're
allowing the body to reset and build up
this concentrated bile in your
gallbladder if you're eating so
frequently your gallbladder might not
have a chance to really build up the
concentration that it needs to do its
magic on your food of extracting these
fat soluble nutrients and number four
low carb which is going to lower the
insulin and number five taking purified
bile salts you'd want to take these
after a meal you might want to take one
or two and sometimes three and that can
greatly assist you in building up your
bile reserve and if you want a really
good bile salt product I put my
recommendation down in the description